so of course police and the fbi have
been working around the clock to learn
how
and why this happened tragically
colorado has experienced this type of
mass shooting before as has america
catherine harris is following all these
developments from washington catherine
good morning to you
what is law enforcement going to look at
as they get into this investigation
well tony good morning authorities will
likely consider the suspect's history
for a possible motive
whether he knew anyone at the store if
he had any previous criminal record
and of course the type of weapon used
and how it was obtained
the shooting is already refocusing
attention on gun laws especially in
colorado
where regulation of assault weapons can
vary city by city
for instance in denver around 25 miles
from boulder
assault weapons are prohibited in
boulder it's not that clear
cut after the 2018 shooting in parkland
florida
boulder passed bans on assault weapons
and large capacity magazines
but earlier this month a county judge
blocked the city from enforcing the bans
the judge found that under colorado law
local governments cannot prohibit
the sale or possession of firearms that
otherwise are legal under state or
federal law
it's unclear whether any of the weapons
that fell under the bans
were used in yesterday's shooting here
in washington the senate judiciary
committee
had already scheduled a hearing for this
morning to examine the issue
which will now take on even greater
urgency overnight senator abey klobuchar
a democrat on the committee said
back to normal cannot mean a return to
horrific gun violence tony
catherine thank you very much